[Music]
and that escalated quickly nurse Oh
submitted by today mother people
goodbye mother bleep oh that's I night I
tried to say that as white as possible
and I think good a a woman was fine for
threatening to stab her mom over pasta
sauce yo that makes sense I tell you
people right am i right oh girl this is
st. girl behavior what the [ __ ] 48 year
old Italian vegan woman oh that's pretty
Italian vegan behavior vegans are
militant bro yeah yeah yeah yeah if you
get a mob if you get a mob wife that's
vegan that's extra cranky her mom 69
years old she put some meat in the sauce
and she's a [ __ ] a bewdley it's what
did they call her a 48 year old girl
that's a girl oh that's what I heard
woman a woman was fine I heard a girl
okay I heard a girl somewhere my best 48
year old woman so she is recently
unemployed and so she moved back with
their mom and this woman was saying that
it's been years since she's even smelled
meat or been in the presence of meat and
so when her when she moved back with her
mom her mom was making this ragu sauce
which has meat in it and then that the
woman she was just so upset like she
kept getting into arguments with her mom
like to stop making you can't do that
you can't move into my house and tell me
what the [ __ ] I should do she's like
she's a Portlandia vegan doesn't sound
like a real person exactly I love it yes
so then she in the finally like I let
this all escalated to one point where
she grabbed a knife from the kitchen and
she like threatened to stab her mom and
she wouldn't stop she said cuz they
making that grand guseong she said if
you won't stop on your own then I'll
make you stop quit making ragu or I'll
stab you in the stomach what the [ __ ]
big but what am I supposed to do your
daddy loves ragu yeah yeah
Wow it's like we're there
really right now I'm going to [ __ ]
stick our depiction of Italian people is
actually just missing Mario jumping
noises 2016 in this whole time they've
been going to court and trying to figure
out like how they're gonna work out
these problems in the judge finally just
reached why don't you just [ __ ] move
out yeah live on her own they're [ __ ]
unemployed ass is too busy trying to
stab her mom yeah so I don't know if she
still lives at the mom yeah yeah hope
she doesn't this is like annoying
roommate thing or it's like annoying
caver thing where it's like someone
stays with you and then like well I had
a buddy stay with me recently and that
was fine he was gonna stay with us for a
couple weeks right but he brings like so
much [ __ ] luggage he's just it's just
him he brought like 19 suitcases I'm not
even exaggerating is he like an
Instagram person though oh he has to
take nice pictures and also is he a girl
no that's what I'm saying okay cuz
usually girls like how he's yeah
melodically are witty valuables no no it
was just like he got kicked out huh well
no he was moving right so he was moving
across the country alright but he
already shipped all his [ __ ] home and
then this was all the stuff who's gonna
live out up for two weeks I'm like dude
for two weeks I went to Europe for two
weeks and I travelled in one suitcase so
did I and I'm girl right yeah and Nikki
had three this cat had [ __ ] 19
suitcases it was like nuts I was like
let me because he came to the door with
just two and I was like oh cool let me
help you with that and he's like all I
got more in the car and then it was we
couldn't do like four trips and it's not
easy go to your place no right I was a
[ __ ] 19 suitcase we filled our entire
that entire red room we have was filled
with all his [ __ ] I would have been like
dude I'm on why don't you get like a
storage space dude I'm like just leo
[ __ ] your car nobody's gonna steal it
[ __ ] no it looks like a pain in the ass
anyway like nobody don't want this [ __ ]
you brought like a humidifier dude he
had like a [ __ ] deflated beach ball
in there for any situation I guess
well when apocalypse happens I want to
be that guy friend
it's [ __ ] California dude why
wouldn't I have a beach balls he's like
[ __ ] him borrow some socks
dude you have a goodwill on the floor
here bro like but no but that's my point
is like he's like I did you a favor and
then like and then he's like hey man can
also use your closet [ __ ] you have to
beat him up I kind of have that right
now so I got this extra mattress and my
brother so I got offered a mattress in
Macau take it but then I'm like I don't
really need it anymore so I'm like hey
big bro do you want it he's like yeah
give me a whatever size am i cool got
you six months later it's still in my
[ __ ] house I'm like please just
sitting up in the hallway please pick up
your [ __ ] mess yeah it's a comfy
mattress too so I'm like I did you a
favor I don't want to sleep on it I'm
still doing you a favor
don't ever say I want to put a bunch of
type this toys here cuz that's where I
put everything in life is that that time
you was at angle wasn't living in his
room and now he is and now I'm gonna
have someone staying in our guest room
for a couple months so I'm like look I
don't have any room so the judge in
Italy with this woman who threatened to
stab the mom he ordered her to pay 400
euros and for a court fine and then
ordered 500 euros to be paid to her
mother for that I wish I could have seen
this episode on People's Court
doo-doo-doo
oh hell yeah 500 euros for [ __ ]
cigarette yeah how much more is that
577 Judge Joe Brown and Judge Judy would
like have a [ __ ] [ __ ] fight over this
oh I wonder if there was a European
Judge Judy or something like that Judge
Joe Brown is this [ __ ] dude whenever he
does his stuff like usually a judge will
face you this way this [ __ ] I
just on the side always like that bro
these TV shows thing well you have
YouTube TV now right Judge Joe Brown
reminds me of Abe's dad you met him
right yeah yeah once yeah he has that
same kind of like just bravado about
nothing well that's because he said he
works as
a psychologist or some our counselor
whale right he was a teacher at a jail
and oh damn he's a [ __ ] G dude that's
probably why he has to deal with
criminals on our how our 8:10 so soft
then you hadn't know how you used to
wake us up as kids
like we would spend the night at each
other's homes at the weekend right so
our parent would take care of each other
off and on and so we would go to his
house is full wake us up like this wake
up idiots he's at Folsom Prison hitting
the [ __ ] mug against the [ __ ] bars
you ain't got [ __ ] yeah you know
we're like whatever like 12 or 13 and
you know we're up all night playing or
some [ __ ] and then we would wake up a
little later but every morning wake up
stupids wake up yeah wake up idiots
that's up guys how lovely I had this
idea for show you good tell me what you
think okay so it's called millennial
court you get it and the show would be
hosted by the son of a popular judge
right so like this son who like lives at
home of the popular judge yeah he is the
judge and it's just like you get a bunch
of like girls who threw a birthday party
and it's like it's like this is Melanie
she threw a birthday party and she
already had a preset reservation where
she had 12 seats but but this and this
is defended Jessica she told Melanie she
RSVP that she was going to the party but
she didn't show up so then she had 11
seats that were filled and not and paid
for and bebeto but she paid for 12 and
and Melanie is also suing because of the
damages of having an empty chair there
exactly yeah people were looking at her
and judging her because of because
people did not everyone showed up and
they're all like thinking like all this
chick doesn't even have that like all
her friends are not loyal and and then I
like it but here's the twist right
because this show the thing that pisses
me off about all these court shows is
that there's never any resolution that
we get to see right it's always like you
will pay him 500 dogs but you don't get
to see them hand a check to the person
and be all pissed and be like here's
their fire two bucks to [ __ ] hate you
so in this show at the end you go to the
house of whoever like whoever wins you
go to their house and then you get to
pick anything in their house so I gets
like you picked their TV
that's it yeah and then the enemy
[ __ ] like rip it off the wall
whatever they're carrying it out while
you stand there all pissed off and [ __ ]
is that not a tight show yeah yeah
that'd be tight cuz I'll just pick that
person's wife so you don't need it right
all right thanks man
wait I don't think this is for the show
wait take the dog but see then you can
see how petty people are cuz if it's
about like a bed or like a if they know
you then they know what you like the
most and see how like so much my
favorite reality TV show back in the day
was a [ __ ] bully beatdown yeah oh
yeah what was that I was really
literally gonna bully and he gets his
ass whooped by a professional MMA
fighter yeah they had people like
[ __ ] Eddie Alvarez on that show dude
like legit like MMA fighters and they
would hook these people ah it was would
they cry some of them yeah they will it
was really good would they do a super
montage of the bully be like I don't
even care about people yeah like that
chick who was talking about black people
the black girl girls big show this guy
like yeah I could fight and he's like
working out doing curls and random [ __ ]
it was beautiful I beat up by five
people is blood
I own this blog I think it was on MTV
yeah I could hear the producers being
like yeah go to do even harder go even
harder yeah yeah well you know I got
I've been in 17 fights he's like I win
16 like that's it there's a dude that
was so into like his muscles or whatever
he was just kind of like a meathead but
this was the only time I actually felt
bad for somebody being in that cage
because usually like the MMA fighters
are going like half speed like not even
have maybe a quarters never a really
easy you know but this would piss cool
I could tell he hated this guy he
literally kicked him in his [ __ ]
chest as he was born I remember that as
you as well as he was falling so he
cracked him and then he went roundhouse
Wow
right in the chest and the guy like
almost it's just a one-sided fight yeah
it is
usually on it they usually are the
bullies actually think they could fight
the bullies either actually think they
can fight or they're into that's like a
toddler versus anime manga yeah
[Music]